right up there we go right
[Music]
up hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Mark Ruffalo he's
one of the most prolific and celebrated
actors of our time from the theater
stage to Oscar winning dramas to iconic
romcoms and historic Hollywood
blockbusters his latest project though
is poor things the yoro L the most
directed dark comedy opening in theaters
this December we're very excited for
that Mark Ruffalo welcome to the show
thanks Sean I'm glad to be here what's
going through your head as you prepare
to take on The Gauntlet are you at all
nervous going into this I am yeah I'm a
little nervous about the bomb and uh um
the uh the goat the ginger goat well
those are two things to be weary of are
you ready to get started over here let's
do this
Sean
[Music]
it's pre- Sauced sorry I should know
that
M I'm still I'm still I feel a little
kicked there it's a little creeper it's
a creeper hot sauce
okay so in Port things who played the
role of a daper lawyer who you've
described as a bomb vant somebody who
enjoys the Finer Things in life and
thinks of himself as the world's
greatest lover was there any sort of
perverse pleasure or joy in playing a
character so self-obsessed
yeah I mean I don't get to play many
parts like that and um honestly I was
scared of it he's a real Casanova and
he's out of control and it's you know
getting to do it it was just so freeing
people have all these expectations on
you and uh and you start to get stuck in
these
boxes and at 55 I'm like sick of that
and so it was just a kind of an
explosion of um of kind of radical
creativity for
[Music]
me all this talking is to avoid moving
to the to the next listen I'm well aware
of the stall tactics okay Mark I've seen
them all You' seen, hours in okay cool
all right but you can't hide anymore
because this next one is the shashido
and garlic here in the two spot all
right here we
go I'm glad I came
hungry that's the way to do
it there's this often quoted Mark
Ruffalo fun fact about this time in your
life a decade plus where you went on an
estimated 800 audition without Landing a
single Ro is there a moment that you
think back on and can pinpoint as being
like your acting Rock Bottom like what
do you think is the closest you ever
came to just giving it up forever so I
probably quit like six times during the
course of it all um the closest was I my
dad had a uh was part of a construction
painting business and um I went to
Wisconsin and I walked on a job site and
I saw some guys like s
blasting and these dudes work I mean
they're covered head to toe and they
got you know all day long and there's
sand blasting them and you're like uh
maybe I should give it one more shot
yeah I was like my hands are too soft
for this but my mom got wind of this I
didn't tell my mom cuz I knew she'd be
bummed right and she got wind of this
and she called me and she's like what
are you doing she says to me if you quit
acting I will never speak to you again I
will be so angry and upset with you and
my I never heard my mom talk like that
and so I was like that
works
dad I talk mom says I should give him
another shot I'm GNA have to go cuz Mom
won't let me mom won't let me quit I got
to get my that's all right
okay got that out of the
way spicy yep and
sweet not too bad heatwise that's good
we're in a good spot right now and yeah
I'm feeling more confident right where
we want you we got you right where we
want
you spank me all
right what do you think is your personal
record for the most takes ever requested
by by a director while you're shooting a
scene you know I read a quote from your
collateral co-star Jamie Fox about how
particular Michael man can be David
Fincher makes Michael man look like he's
working on a McDonald Hamburger
line during rush hour I mean it's like
my first day of work it was a walk and
talk with Jake Gyllenhaal and we're on
take
63 Fincher
he came straight towards me and I was
like oh no here it comes and then he
walks right by me and he he goes to a
background artist behind me he moves him
Ines he starts walking back to the mod
on the back of me on my back and walks
past me and I was like
oh okay I'm just happen to be like 2% of
the frame the other crazy thing is he
invented the delete button for digital
media out of necessity he he's not going
to use it so he's like well why have it
and he literally you'd be in take 50 and
he'd be like delete takes one through
45 and you're
like take 30 was the
[Laughter]
[Music]
one do you get sick of
spice not sick enough to think about
getting a real job if that makes sense
never get a real job yeah right but I
accept it you know what I mean it's a
sacrifice yeah got to suffer for the art
yeah man you have to suffer for the
art so I read that while preparing for
your role as real life Boston Globe
reporter Michael rendes in Spotlight
that you asked him can I see you yell at
someone what does that teach you if
anything other than like how they yell I
had heard that he can be a little hot a
little spicy on some of his uh
calls and so so I asked to sort of take
I wanted to take along with him just to
see how he did his business and uh the
cool thing about being an actor is you
get invited into these worlds that most
people will never be invited into and
people want to tell their stories so
they're very vulnerable and honest with
you in a way and it's just this it's
kind of this peak into Humanity that's
so rare mhm and it just makes it fun and
it and it makes you have an an
appreciation for all different walks of
life and different people you know and
their beliefs and how they came to those
beliefs and so on and so
[Music]
forth it's good now what kind of pepper
is that one it's got uh you need glasses
man yeah I might need yours are you are
you at that point yet oh I don't know I
guess we can try let's see it's hard to
accept actually no I'll try these are
working kind of better those are kind of
hot on you these work yeah man all right
let's see here can you can you read that
literally it's it's like a a fleas
writing we've got a serrano peppers in
this one oh yum serrano peppers all
right and then it says it brings a punch
they're not lying no it does it it's a
creeper yeah it sort of Builds on you
yeah it's a step up here it's a step up
over here uh how about this fact or
fiction is it true that you once
accidentally popped Channing Tatum's ear
during a particular L physical scene are
you joking in Fox catcher where he told
you before the take just slap the
out of me and get it over with oh
there's a lot of
that he did ask me to slap the out
of him and it was easy to do because
he'd beaten the out of me so many
times we had it was like four months of
wrestling of learning how to wrestle
together and he like has 30 lbs on me um
so when it came time to smack the
out of him I was like came from
[Music]
Alabama all right I'll give these back
to you cuz I'm worried about how used to
them I'm getting they're good
right oh GH pepper
mhm gently building in the back yeah of
the pallet yeah this is kind of like the
one that um makes my throat scratch a
little bit yeah I'm starting to get a
little little
um uh what is it called experation oh I
didn't even I did not know that I was
not going to help you out at all there
like a little you know yeah yeah which
what is that called expiration
experation yeah that's like a law in New
York City you're not allowed to exp
forgate oh okay well I'm experting yeah
something fierce right now are you
feeling that yeah I'm
experting what makes Kenneth Lans this
is our youth such a sought-after
playground for young actors it's kind of
crazy the number of people I've
interviewed who have that as part of
their origin story yeah it's like it's
like our generation's Hamlet
um it's just such great writing it's so
welld designed it's sort of that
character becomes a man and an equal to
his friend and those people who are who
were the dominant ones in high school
unless they change it doesn't work out
for them you know going forward and it's
the Geeks or the the nerds or the more
thoughtful people that actually kind of
do well later in their lives it like
pierces the heart of the theater kid
totally it smashes
him the ginger
goat we're going big yeah it's an
explosion I'm yeah yeah oh
yeah same wavelength yeah same page Mark
right now oh yeah I'm down with that
yeah have you ever had Woody harelson on
the show no but I'm dying too you put in
a word for me he has he has this pepper
that he grows in
Hawaii he gives it out in a little vial
like that with a cork oh I've met some
of those guys before it's literally a
matchick amount of that in a freaking
giant pot of chili and that's enough and
it's just
bang it is so intense I he carries one
with him everywhere he goes yeah I know
guys like that too he might be
crossbreeding that stuff himself I think
he is man if anyone knows how to
crossbreed it's him
thaty
sorry can you give us one pro and one
con of having walking Phoenix as a
roommate when the two of you shared a
house while shooting reservation Road
he's a great
cook and he turned me on to um vegan
Cuisine and so he would cook all the
time and he was a great roommate you
know he was a roommate who'd be out and
he you you get a text need anything you
know want need me to pick up anything
the place is clean all the dishes were
washed he's got a great sense of humor
he was super thoughtful and he offered
me to stay there I was supposed to stay
someone else he's like hey man why don't
you stay here I have like three bedrooms
and you're like all right I'll renew the
lease yeah put me on there put me on the
leas this is not my jam this next one
okay that looks it looks serious it has
a little it has a little nuclear fallout
uh yeah yeah and there's a reason for
that they're not lying the label being a
warning is appropriate in this case
Insanity it is beyond Insanity so this
is like the turbo or what is it the
insane button on the Tesla yeah that's
what we're doing we're lighting it up
all right here we go it looks really red
yeah I'm going to take this whole thing
you are let's do it all right I'll go
where you cheers
[Music]
cheers I'm
stupid this thing keeps going I know and
it doesn't stop it doesn't stop and this
has got a nice long over makes it worse
does it kind of always makes it worse
but if we didn't have it on the table
people would ask for it you know what
I'm saying how many more do we have to
go just two more we're so close we're so
close but before we get there yeah you
know you've been an established actor
here now for over three decades you have
dozen long it's been a long time it's
been it's
true dozens and dozens of titles some of
them huge massive Hollywood Blockbusters
others maybe you don't even remember
making them and to put that to the test
I want to play a game where I hit you
with a Mark Ruffalo movie tagline and
you try to connect the tagline to the
movie all right does that sound good
sounds okay when the girl next door when
the girl next door moves across theall
apartment 13 wow there you go one for
one that was like my first movie I
didn't forget that and I remember the
girl across the you know across the
hallway Girl Next Door moved across the
hallway I know I
know I'll tell you something it was so
low budget that I flubbed a take and the
director came up to me and said that was
500 bucks just so you know okay let's go
again I kind of like that keep the
actors accountable you
know how am I supposed to practice my
craft when you're putting a number over
my head man it's that kind of pressure
that's what's going to form a diamond
whatever happened to that director he go
on to become scor Daisy right
basically how about this one forbidden
desire s are Unleashed and unspeakable
evil is
watching that's mirror mirror there you
go good job that might have been my
first
movie there was mirror mirror and then
Mirror Mirror 2 Raven dance yeah yeah
which had a penthouse porn star in the
female lead and Billy Drago in the male
lead and
I oh my God I was the I was like the
serious actor
sidekick and my first it was like a
softcore horror fle that's where I got
my started yeah yeah that was like your
crime procedural yes that's where I got
my that was my brand it's like oh get
get the kid get that Ruffalo
kid how about this one it's a wonderful
afterlife
a I only know one afterlife just like
like Kevin that's it that's it that's it
hold on I need to wipe down oh no my
makeup came
off how you feeling are we doing a
cutaway to a commercial
now you look like you're yeah that's
what we do after the bomb all right and
we'll be right back with more Mark
Ruffalo here on hot ones this is really
well
[Music]
done are you going tongue down I'm going
wherever you take it tongue down all
right tongue down so the hot part on the
tongue all right
full living danger
[Music]
yeah right up there we go right up got
tongue down spice on tongue full on
direct to skin Tong action no
prophylactic m- do you have a favorite
living sculptor that burns twice I know
I know it does there's always a second
act to this show do you have a favorite
living sculptor I know
that that's become like a profound kind
of Escape for you like an outlet for you
okay all right I don't want to blow it
up I don't want to blow it up blow it up
just can you can we take that one back
say I hear you're taking uh like classes
yeah yeah how about won't on the wies
and I'm just be like autographs I'll be
like signing funkos all day long be
there'll be like 10 new people in the
class that just happen to have funkos on
them
right I don't want it's intense I know I
don't want it to turn into the you know
like the baggage claim at the airport or
anything oh dude that yeah you heard
about that oh my God I got Funko too
believe it or not yeah I'll sign your
Funko take out that Funko can can
somebody grab my toy I'm taking them up
on that I'll totally sign your Funko
I'll sign anyone's Funko here all right
my teacher is named arsan he's a he's a
um he's a Russian sculptor he's so
great and I he's he's my favorite living
sculptor right now and he's not super
well known but he's known and he is just
a amazing sculptor and if you wanted to
go online and look up arsin he's on
there and all his work's on there and
he's just
fantastic I knew it I knew you were
going to do that what we sh why I'm
shaking it you got to shake it like
Daddy needs a new pair of
[Music]
shoes man you really slathered that
thing didn't you on accident try not to
do what I did no I'm doing what you did
uh-oh here we go here we go Sean I'm
with you is that like about right yeah
that looks that looks perfect like
they're
like
okay I'll do won't stop you all right
are we doing fies yeah we're doing fies
well I'm going wherever you go but you
would ask if you we going
[Music]
foies bye see you on the other
side become a non-verbal show here at
the
[Music]
end yeah okay I got you I got you yeah
yeah
yeah all right so Mark rafalo to close
things out you know it's been such an
amazing spice Journey with you the highs
the lows the dark days of Serial
auditions and serving up Margaritas to
keep the lights onny you know
everything what would be your advice to
other young aspiring actors like if you
were to come across somebody who'd
likewise had 800 auditions without
booking one would your advice be closer
to never give up or call it
quits you're the only one who could stop
you
you know as any kind of artist you are
the one who says it's enough cuz
sometimes you feel like oh this world is
not is against me doing this I had a lot
of time like that next stay out of
debt do not take on huge debt because
you need time and you can't spend all
your time servicing that debt you got to
be doing your work and number three is
develop yourself right now everyone's on
social media and and everyone's in some
way trying to trying to be the same you
know yeah yeah yeah and it's like stay
off of that and and develop yourself so
you have your own voice it's you who
they're looking for not the next ex you
know develop develop a style develop a
way of
working wise words from Mark Ruffalo and
look at you taking on the wings of death
living to tell the T we crushed wings of
death and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you Mark
Ruffalo thanks this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life um I have
poor things coming out I have um which
is an amazing movie and so much fun what
other there's another camera that one
mhm lots of hi Mark Ruffalo and uh this
is hot
ones thanks for joining um I have uh all
the light we cannot see on Netflix out
right now and I just shot a television
show and that's Howen Harper directed by
the amazing Cooper
Rafe um with Lily Reinhardt and um Betty
Gilpin thank
[Applause]
you you did it you did it that's the
that come man come here we we
we together SAU Brothers Until the End
Brothers thank you man thank you that
was great
I had a great time I was
scared really nice to meet nice meet you
man that was great you're a great
interviewer man that was that was really
in depth well we got to meet you halfway
you did some old Cuts man yeah yeah yeah
yeah some deep Cuts it's fun to dive
into the material you know like that's
the part that I I like about it you
you're really good at it thank you Mark
I appreciate that blessing everybody
nice to meet you nice meeting you
where's your Funko oh yeah yeah yeah
somebody got my
toy
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans with an announcement truth
or dab the game now has a brand new
refresh Edition that's right if you
already had the original truth or dab
game you can now get even more hotter
questions with the refresh Edition the
game is simple answer deeply personal
and potentially awkward questions or
face the Wrath of the last da that's
right both additions of The Game feature
a mini bottle of the last da hot sauce
check out the description below to see
where you can pick up hot ones truth or
dab the game or visit Wilder toys.com
[Music]